hier an der südspitze von manhattan
später so genannte immigration für die
migranten nicht mehr abgerissen
gerade weil er sagte vielleicht ist das
auch eine frau die die männer sieht und
weil die kleine brücke hat wird die nach
hause geschickt und hier hingekommen
also die kleine brücke pont und
agierende neue heimat gefunden
das wäre natürlich dann würde der neue
amerikanische fall keine verbindung mehr
hätte mit diesem kleinen aber ich
distanziere mich von ihm mit das ist
nicht meine
aber hier in der nähe vom world trade
center
architektonische schön eine neue
shopping mall gebaut haben wir nicht
bekommen wir wieder architekten santiago
calatrava heitz werde ausgebaut
das ist ein spanier ein mexikaner also
so gesehen milliarden euro und hier aber
wie gesagt erinnert ein bisschen an
einen truthahn kann man leben an ein
adler carola ist doch wie ein hinweis
auf die spur verlor
aber es wäre schön geworden sagen immer
möglich
oder
tolle nummer
wer aber klar auf die straße kippen ist
entwicklungs auch verboten wenn dann nur
in größeren gruppen und im russischen st
die